[Aplausos]
más
amigos delegados y distinguidos
invitados por favor estoy aquí ante
ustedes esta noche honrado por su apoyo
orgulloso del progreso extraordinario
que hemos logrado en los últimos cuatro
años increíbles y lleno de confianza en
un futuro brillante que construiremos
para eeuu en los próximos cuatro años
muy bien comenzamos esta noche nuestros
pensamientos están con la gente
maravillosa que acaba de pasar y de
sentir la ira del huracán
laura estamos trabajando con los
oficiales locales y estatales en texas
louisiana arkansas misisipí y no estamos
dejando de lado ningún esfuerzo fue uno
de los órganos más fuertes en tocar
tierra en 150 años
los daños fueron mucho menor de los
esperados hace solo 24 horas
y esto se debe al gran trabajo de firma
de las autoridades y de los estados de
manera individual a donde yo iré este
fin de semana para felicitarlos por ese
gran trabajo que realmente apreciamos
somos una gran familia nacional y
siempre vamos a proteger el amor y el
cuidado de unos por otros aquí esta
noche están las personas que han hecho
que este camino para mí haya sido
posible y han llenado mi vida con tanta
alegría por su gran servicio la nación y
por sus hijos quiero agradecer a nuestra
magnífica primera dama
y también quiero agradecer a mi
increíble hija ivanka por esta
presentación y a todos mis hijos iván
que por favor levante
a todos mis hijos y los amo más de lo
que las palabras pueden expresar sé que
mi hermano robert nos está mirando desde
el cielo en este momento fue un gran
hermano y estaba muy orgulloso del
trabajo que todos nosotros estamos
haciendo muchas gracias te amamos
roberts
claro apreciamos también mostramos
nuestro precio por un hombre que siempre
ha luchado
y se ha levantado por nuestros valores
un hombre de una fe profunda y de gran
convicción nuestro vicepresidente
michaels
[Aplausos]
está aquí con su querida esposa una
madre militar con intensas
[Aplausos]
esta noche con un corazón lleno de
optimismo y gratitud acepto esta
denominación para presidente de los eeuu
[Aplausos]
blake y el partido republicano el
partido de abraham lincoln avanza unido
determinado y listo para dar la
bienvenida demócratas independientes y a
cualquiera que crea en la grandeza de
eeuu y el corazón recto del pueblo
estadounidense
en un nuevo término como presidente
vamos a construir de nuevo la mejor
economía de la historia de manera rápida
regresando al empleo total y al aumento
de los ingresos y a una prosperidad
récord
vamos a defender a eeuu en contra de
todas las amenazas ya proteger a los
estadounidenses en contra de todos los
peligros vamos a liderar y llevar este
país a nuevas fronteras de ambiciones y
descubrimientos y vamos a analizar y
buscar nuevas alturas en los logros
nacionales vamos a tener una nueva fe en
nuestros valores nuevo orgullo en
nuestra historia y un nuevo espíritu de
unidad que solamente puede ser cumplido
a través del amor por nuestro gran país
[Aplausos]
porque comprendemos que eeuu no es un
lugar oscuro eeuu es la antorcha que
ilumina el mundo entero
reunidos aquí en nuestra majestuosa casa
blanca conocido en todo el mundo como la
casa del pueblo solamente podemos
maravillarnos por el milagro que es
nuestra gran historia estadounidense
este ha sido el hogar de grandes figuras
como teddy roosevelt jackson que unió a
los estadounidenses con nuevas visiones
de un futuro brillante en estas paredes
también vivieron grandes generales
tenaces como
eisenhower que miraron a nuestros
soldados por la causa de la libertad
desde estos lugares
thomas jefferson
[Música]
los enviar una expedición por el
continente en las profundidades de una
guerra civil se en gris el presidente
abraham lincoln
miro por estas mismas ventanas para
completar el del monumento a washington
y preguntarle a dios en su providencia y
pedirle que salvará nuestra nación
dos semanas después de harvard
winston churchill y justo adentro
pusieron a llevar a nuestro pueblo en un
curso hacia la victoria en la segunda
guerra mundial y en días recientes
nuestra nación y todo el planeta ha sido
golpeado
por un nuevo y poderoso enemigo
invisible como esos estadounidenses
valientes antes de nosotros nos estamos
enfrentando al reto estamos
cumpliendo con terapias que salvan vidas
y estamos y vamos a producir una vacuna
antes del final del año o incluso
posiblemente antes
vamos a derrotar al virus y la pandemia
y vamos a salir de ahí más fuertes que
nunca antes
[Aplausos]
y oraciones pasadas fue una confianza en
el destino estadounidense y una fe
inquebrantable en el pueblo de este país
sabían que nuestro país está bendecido
por dios y tiene un propósito especial
en este mundo es esa convicción la que
ha inspirado la formación de nuestra
unión de nuestra expansión la abolición
de la esclavitud la aprobación de los
derechos civiles el programa espacial y
el derrocamiento del fascismo la tiranía
y el comunismo este espíritu
estadounidense ha superado todo reto y
nos ha levantado a la cumbre de las
acciones humanas
y a pesar de toda esta grandeza está es
una nación donde lo que hemos logrado
ahora está en peligro
esta es la elección más importante en la
historia de nuestro país
[Aplausos]
gracias en ningún otro momento los
votantes se han enfrentado una opción
más clara entre dos partidos entre dos
visiones dos filosofías o dos agendas
esta elección va a decidir si salvamos
el sueño americano o si permitimos que
una agenda de socialistas acabe con
nuestro querido destino
va a decidir si rápidamente podemos
crear nuevos empleos por millones o si
acabamos con nuestras industrias y
enviamos millones de estos empleos al
exterior como se ha hecho durante tantas
décadas de manera tonta su voto va a
decidir si protegemos a los
estadounidenses que respetan la ley o si
le damos un reino libre a la violencia y
a los anarquistas a los agitadores y a
los criminales que amenazan a nuestros
ciudadanos en esta elección vamos a
decidir si vamos a defender la vida
estadounidense o si vamos a permitir que
un movimiento radical desmantele
totalmente este sueño y lo destruya
[Aplausos]
en la convención nacional demócrata joe
biden y su partido repitieron y
mostraron a este país como un lugar de
injusticia racial y económica así que
esta noche les hago una simple pregunta
cómo puede el partido demócrata liderar
nuestro país cuando pasa tanto tiempo
dañando a este país
[Aplausos]
en la visión cristiano ven a estados
unidos como la nación más excepcional y
libre y justa del mundo sino que ven una
nación debilitada que debe ser castigada
por sus pecados mi oponente dice que la
redención solamente puede venir dándole
el poder a ellos
este es un himno que ha sido
representado por cada movimiento
represivo en la historia pero en este
país no miramos a los políticos ya no
busco nos buscamos a los políticos de
carrera buscando salvación yo buscamos
al gobierno para que nos restaure
ponemos nuestra fe en dios todopoderoso
[Aplausos]
yo by the no es un salvador de el alma
estadounidense es el destructor de los
trabajos estadounidenses y sin ceder a
la oportunidad será el destructor de la
grandeza esta conciencia durante 47 años
joe biden tomó las donaciones de los
obreros les dio abrazos y besos
y les dijo que sentía su dolor y después
voló de regreso a washington y voto para
enviar nuestros trabajos a china y en
muchas otras tierras distantes yo bailé
pasó toda su carrera
llevándose a sus sueños y también los
sueños de trabajadores estadounidenses
abriendo las fronteras y enviando a sus
hijos e hijas a luchar en guerras
extranjeras eternas que nunca terminaron
hace cuatro años me lancé a presidente
porque no podía ver esta tradición de
nuestro país por más tiempo
no podía sentarme y ver como los
políticos de carrera dejaban que otros
tomaran ventaja de nosotros en política
exterior y en defensa y en el comercio
nuestros socios de la otan como por
ejemplo estaban muy por detrás en sus
pagos en materia de defensa pero
bajo mi pedido
para pagar 130 mil millones más cada año
y esos 130.000 millones de dólares
finalmente aumentaron a 400 mil millones
por año y el secretario general
stoltenberg que lidera la otan se vio
sorprendido después de ver como por
tantos años esto ocurría y mismo el
presidente hizo lo que ningún otro fue
capaz de hacer
ramon alabart formal live cuando dejé mi
vida tradicional atrás así que era una
vida muy buena
no he hecho nada más que luchar por
ustedes
hice lo que nuestro establecimiento
político nunca espero y cambiar las las
reglas de washington cumplí con mi
promesa
[Aplausos]
juntos hemos acabado la clase política
de mi gente y están desesperados por
retomar el poder por cualquier medio
necesario y ustedes lo han visto
están enojados conmigo porque en lugar
de ponerlos a ellos deprimidos yo
simplemente dije eeuu primero
gracias julio después de tomar el cargo
el sumamos a washington y su
establecimiento y nos retiramos de el pp
que era un tratado comercial que estaba
acabando con los empleos a proveer las
los oleoductos de kingston
y acabé
con el acuerdo climático de parís que
era tan costoso y por primera vez logre
la independencia energética en el país
[Aplausos]
cortes a las regulaciones y a los
impuestos a una tasa y a una velocidad
que nunca antes se había visto en
cuestión de tres años construimos la
economía más fuerte en la historia del
mundo guasch los insiders de washington
me pidieron que no me enfrentara el
chino y que bien que permitiremos que
china subiera robando nuestros empleos
pero yo mantuve mi palabra al pueblo
estadounidense nos enfrentamos a chinas
con las acciones más audaces y robustas
en la historia estadounidense de lejos
die zeit derwall bien dijeron que sería
imposible reemplazar el nafta
pero de nuevo estaban equivocados este
año acabe con la pesadilla de nafta y
firmé el nuevo de mexico
el acuerdo con méxico y canadá
y ahora las compañías automotrices y
muchos otros están construyendo sus
empresas y plantas en estados unidos no
despidiendo a sus empleados y no nos
están desertando yéndose a otros países
[Aplausos]
tal vez en ninguna otra aérea los
intereses especiales trataron de
detenernos que mi política debe estar en
pro de
la inmigración
[Aplausos]
pero hoy las centros estadounidenses son
más seguras que nunca antes
wilander acabamos con la posibilidad de
atrapar sal y liberación nos enfrentamos
a los traficantes que atacaban a las
mujeres y niños
y hemos deportado a 20.000 miembros de
pandillas y 500.000
extranjeros ilegales criminales hemos
construido 300 millas de muro fronterizo
y estamos agregando 10 millas cada
semana el muro pronto estará terminado y
está funcionando más allá de nuestras
expectativas
esta tarde tenemos aquí miembros de las
fuerzas de patrulla que están
representando a nuestros agentes de
patrulla a nuestros agentes fronterizos
gracias por estar aquí gracias por su
trabajo valiente
en este país como ama a sus autoridades
y realmente es así los amamos y los
respetamos
[Aplausos]
en comentaré que las autoridades de
tennessee habían despedido a miles de
trabajadores
está bien reemplazado por trabajos o por
trabajadores más baratos ahora esos
trabajadores talentosos han sido
recontratados y están de nuevo
entregándole energía a kentucky
mississippi north caroline y virginia
tienen de regreso sus trabajos y muchos
están aquí esta noche por favor levanten
ya han pasado por mucho
el mes pasado me enfrenté a las
industrias farmacéuticas creen que eso
es fácil no lo es y firmé órdenes que
van a reducir los costos de sus
medicamentos por prescripción y le darán
a los pacientes críticamente enfermos
acceso a curas y aprobamos el
la ley del derecho a probar
[Aplausos]
también aprobamos la rendición de
cuentas para los asuntos de los
veteranos para proteger a nuestros
grandes veteranos
[Aplausos]
91% de ellos me aprueba la primera vez
que eso ha ocurrido al final de mi
primer mandato habremos aprobado más de
300 jueces federales incluyendo dos
grandes jueces para la corte suprema
[Aplausos]
y para atraer la prosperidad en nuestras
ciudades deprimidas aprobamos una
reforma que elimina una reforma a la
justicia penal
creamos zonas de oportunidades y
financiamos a las universidades
históricamente afroamericanas y antes de
que llegara el virus de china producimos
los mejores cifras de empleo para los
hispanos afroamericanos y los asiáticos
que jamás hayan sido registradas en el
país
y lo digo de manera modesta que he hecho
más por la comunidad afroamericana que
ningún otro presidente desde abraham
lincoln nuestro primer presidente
republicano
[Aplausos]
y he hecho más en tres años por la
comunidad afroamericana que yo vaivén ha
hecho por ellos en 47 años
buena memoria la que cuando me reelijan
lo mejor aún está por venir
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
cuando tome el cargo en medio oriente
estaba en un caos absoluto y si estaba
creciendo irán estaba también
levantándose ahí la guerra en afganistán
no parecía tener fin yo me retiré del
terrible
acuerdo nuclear con irán
[Aplausos]
mantuve mi promesa reconociendo la
verdadera capital de israel y enviando
ahí
nuestra embajada a jerusalén
[Aplausos]
pero no solamente hablamos como esto de
algo futuro sino que lo construimos en
lugar de pasar de gastar mil millones de
dólares en un nuevo edificio como
planeado tomamos ya un edificio
existente en una mejor ubicación es un
trato inmobiliario al fin y al cabo y lo
abrimos por un costo de menos de 500 mil
dólares
y también reconocimos la soberanía de
israel sobre los altos del golán y este
mes logramos el primer acuerdo de paz
en 25 años
[Música]
gracias a israel y gracias a los
emiratos árabes universidad
y además acabamos con 100% del califato
de isis y matamos a su fundador y líder
abu bakr al bagdadí
y esa operación separada eliminada
terminamos al terrorista número uno del
mundo
[Aplausos]
a diferencia de otras administraciones
yo he mantenido eeuu lejos nuevas
guerras y nuestras tropas están
regresando a casa
hemos estado cerca de 2.5 billones de
dólares para reconstruir de manera total
nuestras fuerzas militares que estaba
fuertemente debilitada cuando yo llegué
al cargo
esto incluye aumentos salariales para
nuestros grandes guerreros
también lanzamos la fuerza espacial
la primera nueva rama desde que se creó
la fuerza aérea hacia hace casi 75 años
hemos pasado los últimos cuatro años
echando para atrás los daños que yo bien
ha creado durante los últimos 47 el
récord de bardem es una vergüenza y un
recuerdo de las peores tradiciones de
nuestra vida
él ha pasado toda su carrera del lado
incorrecto de la historia votó por el
desastre de nafta el peor acuerdo
comercial que jamás se haya aplicado
apoyó la entrada de china a la
organización mundial del comercio uno de
los mayores desastres de todos los
tiempos y después de esas calamidades
debate en eeuu perdió uno de cada cuatro
trabajos de manufactura ustedes pidieron
personas de michigan pensilvania
y en muchos otros estados
y no querían escuchar las palabras
vacías de baile de empatía simplemente
querían que volvieran sus empleos
como vicepresidente el apoyo al pp que
hubiese sido una sentencia de muerte
para la industria automotriz nacional y
apoyó el terrible acuerdo comercial con
corea del sur que se llevó muchos
empleos de nuestro país y que yo también
acabé creando un nuevo acuerdo para el
país apoyó la amnistía masiva para los
ilegales voto a favor de la guerra en
irak
opuso a la misión para acabar con osama
bin laden se opuso a meter
solimán y apoyó el crecimiento de china
como un como algo positivo para ti y
para estados unidos y para juntos es por
eso que china apoya a joe biden y
desesperadamente quieren que gane y
puedo decirles eso basado en información
muy correcta
china sería dueño de nuestro país si yo
bailé en selecto
a diferencia de bailén yo les haría
rendir cuentas por la tragedia que ellos
han causado en todo el mundo en meses
recientes la nación y el planeta han
sido golpeados por una pandemia de una
vez en un siglo algo que china permitió
que se expandiera por todo el planeta
pudieron haberlo detenido pero
permitieron que saliera
estamos agradecidos
con los trabajadores de primera línea
los médicos y enfermeras por favor
levántense y acepten nuestra gratitud
marimar que muchos estadounidenses
incluyéndome hemos partido amigos y
seres queridos con esta enfermedad
horrible como una nación sentimos el
dolor y la pena y llevamos en nuestros
corazones las memorias de todas esas
vidas que han sido perdidas y se han
llevado de manera trágica en su honor
nos vamos a unir y en su memoria vamos a
superar y cuando el virus chino golpeó
lanzamos la mayor movilización desde la
segunda guerra mundial invocando el de
france production act producimos la
mayor cantidad de respiradores ni un
solo estadounidense que alguna vez
necesita un respirador se le negó lo
cual es un milagro
gran trabajo dando esa fuerza de trabajo
por parte de nuestro gran vicepresidente
michaels
[Aplausos]
digamos millones de máscaras y guantes y
equipo de protección a nuestros
trabajadores para proteger a estas
personas estamos dando kits de prueba y
también a los hogares para la tercera
edad les damos todo lo que ha necesitado
porque estamos cuidando de las personas
de la tercera edad
[Aplausos]
el equipo de ingenieros construyó
hospitales y también creamos hospitales
en barcos creamos desde cero el mayor
sistema de pruebas del mundo
y eeuu ha hecho más pruebas que todos
los países de europa combinados y más
que ningún otro país del hemisferio
occidental piensa en eso hemos llevado a
cabo 40 millones de pruebas más que
creamos tratamientos incluyendo el
plasma compareciente vimos eso el
domingo en la noche cuando anunciamos
que esto va a salvar miles y miles de
vidas hemos sido pioneros
y vemos las cifras que es la tasa de
mortalidad se ha reducido en un 80 por
ciento desde abril
[Aplausos]
eeuu está entre los países con menor
cantidad en esa tasa en europa de cerca
de tres veces más grande que la nuestra
pero ellos aquí no escriben y reportan
eso no quieren que ustedes sepan eso las
naciones de europa han experimentado un
aumento en la mortalidad en exceso más
que en eeuu hemos aprobado el mayor
paquete de alivio en la historia del
país gracias a nuestro paquete de
protección de cheques hemos también
apoyado más de 50 millones de empleos
estadounidenses y es una de las razones
por las cuales estamos avanzando de
manera tan rápida
con la economía como resultado estamos
creciendo en la menor contracción de
cualquier nación occidental y estamos
recuperándonos a una tasa mucho más
rápida en los últimos tres meses hemos
tomado nuevos millones de empleos y ese
es un récord en la historia nacional
[Aplausos]
desafortunadamente desde el principio
nuestros oponentes se han mostrado
capaces de nada más que una habilidad
partidista para criticar cuando yo tomé
una acción audaz para imponer una
prohibición de viajes a china de manera
temprana
joe biden se puso histérico y dijo que
era algo histérico en la calificó de
xenofóbica y también hicimos lo mismo
con europa de manera temprana si
hubiésemos escuchado a joe miles de
estadounidenses habrían muerto y en
lugar de seguir la ciencia yo bailén
quiere crear un nuevo cierre para todo
el país un nuevo cierre generaría un
daño irreparable para los niños para las
familias y para los ciudadanos de todos
los orígenes el costo de un cierre de
bailín sería medido en las sobredosis en
las depresiones en las adicciones al
alcohol en los suicidios
los ataques al corazón la devastación
económica la pérdida de empleos y mucho
más
el plan de joe biden no es una solución
al virus sino más bien una rendición
ante el virus
es mi administración tiene un enfoque
muy distinto salvar cuantas vidas sean
posibles y para eso estamos apoyándonos
en los datos y en las ciencias estamos
de manera estamos protegiendo a las
personas en riesgo particularmente a las
personas de la tercera edad mientras que
permitimos que quienes no están en
riesgo puedan regresar de manera segura
al trabajo y a la escuela y queremos ver
a tantas de esos estados y queremos que
estén abiertas tienen que volver al
trabajo
[Aplausos]
tiene que volver a trabajar y también
las escuelas lo más importante también
estamos trabajando con los genios
científicos para producir una vacuna en
tiempo récord bajo la operación work
spirit vemos tenemos 13 vacunas en la
última fase de pruebas
años por delante de lo que ha sido
logrado antes nadie jamás pensó que se
pudiera hacer de manera tan rápida si se
hace normalmente en años pero lo hicimos
en meses y estamos creando estos avances
para que millones de dosis sean
disponibles de manera rápidas
tendremos una vacuna segura este año y
juntos vamos a aplastar el virus
en la convención demócrata apenas
ustedes escucharon una palabra sobre su
agenda pero eso no es porque no tengan
uno sino porque su agenda que se las son
las propuestas más extremas que jamás se
han adelantado por parte de un nominado
de un gran partido yo vaivén dice que es
un aliado de la luz pero cuando se trata
de su agenda vaivén quiere mantenernos
absolutamente en la oscuridad no
entiende nada él ha prometido un aumento
de cuatro millones de dólares en
impuestos para las familias que haría
colapsar nuestra economía que se está
recuperando rápidamente y también los
mercados de valores que ahora están en
situación récord también colapsaría
han pensado en todas las acciones que
tienen y como dicen mi primer término
voy a recortar aún más los impuestos
para las madres trabajadoras y los
padres no voy a aumentar impuestos los
voy a reducir de manera sustancial
y también vamos a ofrecer créditos
fiscales para que regresen los empleos
de china a eeuu e impondremos castigos
para las empresas que se lleven los
empleos fuera de la nación
vamos a asegurarnos que las compañías y
los trabajos se queden en este país como
ya lo he estado haciendo desde hace ya
bastante tiempo si se han dado cuenta la
agenda de joe biden
es hecho en china mi agenda es hecho en
eeuu
[Aplausos]
y pueden ha prometido acabar con la
producción de petróleo de carbón y de
gas natural
acabando con las economías de
pensilvania ohio texas dakota del norte
oklahoma colorado y nuevo méxico va a
destruir esos estados totalmente así
como otros millones de empleos se
perderán y los precios de la energía van
a un altar esas mismas políticas
llevaron a los cortes de electricidad
apenas en california la semana pasada a
todo el mundo lo vio
nadie ha visto algo como esto vimos la
semana pasada en california como puede
yo vaivén decir que es un aliado de la
luz cuando su propio partido ni siquiera
puede mantener las luces encendidas
solvay busquen esta campaña de baile
incluso ha publicado
una plataforma de 110 páginas que
también ha sido descrita por el senador
el 'loco' bernie sanders el manifiesto
de bardem y berni quiere
suspender la remoción de ilegales
reinstaurar catch and release y darle
a estos criminales y esos ilegales
abogados para todos eso es lo que
necesitamos más abogados
no pueden recientemente levantó una mano
en el debate
y dijo que iba a dar de manera gratuita
sus dólares para los ilegales dándole el
servicio de salud lo que va a atraer aún
más ilegales en cifras masivas personas
que van a entrar al país y van a obtener
todas las cosas que quieren educación
salud todo también apoya las ciudades
santuario que protegen a los ilegales
criminales prometió acabar con
las prohibiciones de viaje- de naciones
y cadistas y también a aumentar
la llegada a refugiados en un 700 por
ciento esto está en el ser manifestó el
plan de bailén va a eliminar las
fronteras del país en medio de una
pandemia mundial e incluso está hablando
de acabar con el muro de tumbar lo que
tal eso
también se opone a la elección libre de
escuelas todas las escuelas chárter
acabando con las oportunidades para los
niños hispanos y afroamericanos yo voy a
expandir esas escuelas y le daré la
opción a las familias de elegir la
escuela que quieran para sus hijos
y aquí siempre vamos a tratar a nuestros
maestros con un respeto tremendo el que
merecen
grandes personas grandes personas job
aiden dice que tiene empatía que siente
empatía por los vulnerables y el partido
que lidera apoya los abortos en el
estado avanzado de bebés inocentes
los líderes demócratas hablan de
decencia moral pero no tienen problemas
con detener el corazón latiente de un
bebé en el noveno mes de embarazo los
políticos demócratas se rehúsan a
proteger las vidas inocentes y después
nos dan clases de moralidad
y de salvarla el alma de eeuu hoy
declaramos de manera orgullosa que todos
los niños nacidos si no tienen un
derecho a la vida
[Aplausos]
desde la convención demócrata
las palabras bajo dios se eliminaron del
juramento de lealtad de lealtad no una
sino dos veces nosotros nunca haríamos
algo así pero el hecho es que
aquí es de dónde vienen
si la izquierda obtiene poder va a
acabar con los suburbios van a confiscar
sus armas y va a designar jueces que van
a acabar con su segunda enmienda y con
otros otras libertades constitucionales
bailén es un caballo de troya para el
socialismo no tiene la fortaleza para
enfrentarse a marxistas como bernie
sanders y sus otros radicales de los
cuales hay muchos nos vemos todo el
tiempo es algo realmente increíble
entonces como se va a enfrentar o como
se va a levantar para defenderlos a
ustedes el aspecto más peligroso de la
plataforma de baile es el ataque a la
seguridad pública el manifesto de verón
y bailén pide acabar con las fianzas en
efectivo lo cual liberaría a miles de
criminales en sus barrios y cuando le
preguntan si apoya recortar los fondos
para lados para la policía el responde
sí absolutamente cuando la congresista
y la llamó a la policía de mirada por un
cáncer podrido hasta la raíz él no iba
a rechazar su apoyo
poco después incluso lo mostró en su
página web con grandes letras no se
equivoquen si le dan poder a joe biden a
la izquierda radical va a desfinanciar
los departamentos de policía en todo el
país van a aprobar leyes federales para
reducir la policía a nivel nacional van
a hacer que cada ciudad se ve como
portland oregón nadie estaría seguro en
eeuu de baile en mi administración
siempre va a defender a los hombres y
mujeres de las autoridades
cada día los oficiales de la policía
arriesgan sus vidas para mantenernos
seguros y cada año muchos sacrifican sus
vidas en la línea de uno de ellos fue en
fue miembro de la policía de nueva york
y recibimos su apoyo apenas hace unos
días son grandes personas
[Aplausos]
si se les permitiera hacer su trabajo no
tendrían crimen en nueva york' y rudy
giuliani lo sabe perfectamente
hace 3 años el 4 de julio en la
respectiva familia estaba trabajando
cuando fue emboscada después de la
medianoche y asesinado por
un monstruo que lo odiaba simplemente
por llevar la placa
recientemente pidió tiempo libre la
madre para poder pasar más tiempo con
sus hijos y estuve en el capitolio con
esos hijos hermosos y la tomé la mano de
su abuela mientras sentían el dolor por
su pérdida terrible y honramos al
detective de familia y su
vida los tres hijos del detective
familias están con nosotros aquí esta
noche en danés peter de laila nos
sentimos tan orgullosos de tenerlos aquí
esta noche muchas gracias
y vamos a llevar a su madre en nuestros
corazones para siempre debemos recordar
que la gran mayoría de los oficiales de
la policía son buenos y esa es la
abrumadora mayoría son nobles llenos de
coraje y tenemos que darle a los
oficiales
el poder de nuevo
[Aplausos]
podría perder sus pensiones tienen miedo
de perder sus empleos y al estar
asustados no son capaces de hacer el
trabajo que tan desesperadamente tienen
que hacer por ustedes y aquellos que
sufren más son las grandes personas que
protegen y que quieren proteger
a un nivel incluso mayor cuando hay
injusticias en este sistema se debe
hacer que estas personas rindan cuentas
de manera total y así será pero nunca
podemos tener una situación donde las
cosas estén como están hoy nunca debemos
permitir que las muchedumbres liberen
[Aplausos]
en los términos más fuertes en el
partido republicano condena los saqueos
los incendios que hemos visto así como
los disturbios particularmente en
ciudades lideradas por demócratas como
portland que no sé y otras hay peligro
en las calles de las ciudades lideradas
por demócratas del país y este problema
se podría arreglar rápidamente si
quisieran simplemente llamen estamos
listos para entrar en nos vamos a ocupar
de su problema en cuestión de horas
simplemente llamen tenemos que esperar
su llamada tenemos que esperar que nos
llamen más siempre tenemos que tener ley
y orden todo sin crimen federal está
siendo perseguido con todo el peso de la
ley
cuando los anarquistas empezaron a
acabar con nuestros monumentos y
estatuas aquí afuera yo firmé una orden
de manera inmediata diez años de prisión
y fue un milagro todo se detuvo
donde tumbar las estatuas cuando miraron
las estatuas decían 10 años es mucho
tiempo
vámonos a casa
durante su convención núcleo bailen y lo
apoyan y se mantuvieron en silencio
sobre estos criminales y agitadores que
generan ese caos en las ciudades
demócratas ni siquiera lo mencionaron
durante toda la convención ni una sola
vez ahora están comenzando a mencionarlo
porque están bajando
sus cifras de aprobación es demasiado
tarde
ante la anarquía de izquierda en
minneapolis chicago y otras ciudades
joe biden y su campaña no la condenaron
al contrario donaron al menos 13
miembros de la campaña de biden
donaron a un fondo para sacar a estos
anarquistas a estos agitadores y aquí
esta noche está la familia de el capitán
david turner un veterano de 20 años de
la policía de san luís un gran hombre y
un hombre muy respetado por todos y fue
asesinado cuando estaba tratando de
proteger una tienda de los agitadores y
de los saqueadores o como dirían los
demócratas manifestantes pacíficos les
dicen manifestantes pacíficos estamos
honrados de estar aquí esta noche
con su magnífica esposa año y sus
hermanos que ley en nunca vamos a
olvidar los el legado heroico del
capitán dave y turnos muchas gracias por
estar aquí
muchas gracias un gran hombre
mientras yo sea presidente voy a
defender el derecho de cada ciudadano
estadounidense a vivir en seguridad
dignidad y paz si el partido demócrata
quiere quedarse del lado de los
anarquistas los aplicadores los
saqueadores y los incendiarios ese es su
problema pero mientras yo sea su
presidente no seremos parte de esto el
partido republicano será y seguirá
siendo la voz de los héroes patriotas
que mantiene a eeuu segura y salud
haremos la bandera estadounidense
[Aplausos]
el año pasado más de 1000 afroamericanos
fueron asesinados como el resultado de
la violencia en ciudades lideradas por
demócratas y en el top 10 de las
ciudades más peligrosas del país todas
son lideradas por demócratas y ha sido
así durante décadas miles de
afroamericanos son víctimas
del crimen violento en estas comunidades
yo vaivén y la izquierda ignoran a estos
víctimas estadounidenses yo nunca lo
haré si la izquierda radical toma el
poder van a aplicar sus políticas para
cada ciudad suburbio pueblo del país
simplemente imaginen si los llamados
manifestantes pacíficos estuvieran a
cargo de cada
a nivel de poder en el gobierno
estadounidense estos políticos dicen
estar preocupados por la fortaleza de
las instituciones estadounidenses pero
quien exactamente las está atacando
quien está contratando a estos los
jueces y quien está tratando de acabar
con la aplicación de la ley migratoria y
creando
códigos de discurso para acallar a otros
siempre se trata de miembros de la
izquierda radical siempre recuerden que
vienen detrás de mí porque yo estoy
luchando por ustedes eso es lo que
ocurre
desde incluso antes de que me dirigiera
y recuerden estos ellos esperaron mi
campaña y fueron atrapados ahora veamos
qué ocurre tenemos que retomar nuestra
independencia de los mandatos represivos
de la izquierda eeuu estadounidenses
están exhaustos tratando de mantenerse
con la nueva lista de palabras y frases
aprobadas en un mundo cada vez más
restrictivo y sus decretos políticos
muchas cosas tienen un nombre distinto
ahora y las reglas están cambiando
constantemente el objetivo de la cultura
de la cancelación es hacer es asegurarse
que muchos viven en el miedo sean
puestos bajo vergüenza humillados y
eliminados de la sociedad como tal
izquierda radical quieren llevarlos a
decir lo que ustedes saben que es falso
y asustarlos para que no digan lo que
saben que es cierto eso es algo muy
triste
pero el 3 de noviembre ustedes pueden
enviarles un mensaje poderoso que nunca
van a olvidar
gracias
[Aplausos]
es débil en tomar sus órdenes de los
hipócritas liberales que acaban con sus
ciudades mientras se alejan de los
lugares del caos estos mismos liberales
quieren eliminar con la elección libre
de escuelas
quieren abrir nuestras fronteras
mientras viven en sitios cerrados y en
comunidades en los mejores barrios del
mundo quieren desfinanciar a la policía
mientras ellos tienen guardias armados
particulares y en noviembre debemos
voltear la página
a esta clase política fallida el hecho
es que yo estoy aquí
como se llame este edificio
pero lo diré de otra manera el hecho es
que nosotros estamos aquí y ellos no
además para mí uno de los edificios más
bellos del mundo no es un edificio es un
hogar en lo que a mí respecta no es una
casa es un hogar es un lugar hermoso con
una historia increíble pero es todo por
ustedes juntos vamos a escribir el nuevo
capítulo de la gran historia
estadounidense en los próximos cuatro
años vamos a hacer que eeuu sea un
superpoder de manufactura en el mundo
vamos a expandir las zonas de
oportunidad
gracias a tim scott nos vamos a traer a
casa a nuestras cadenas de suministro
médico
mantenemos la resiliencia
no vamos a depender ni un poco de china
vamos a sacar a nuestros negocios de
china los estamos trayendo de nuevo a
casa queremos que estos negocios
regresen a casa y continuaremos
reduciendo los impuestos y las
regulaciones a niveles que nunca antes
se han visto vamos a crear 10 millones
de empleos en los próximos 10 meses y
será incluso más que eso vamos a
contratar a más policía a aumentar más
que los castigos para aquellos que
ataquen a los oficiales y ya veremos
oficiales a las comunidades con altos
tasas de criminalidad nos aseguraremos
que la salud sea protegida para los
ciudadanos y no para los ilegales
tenemos fronteras fuertes
lo he dicho durante años sin fronteras
no tenemos país
y acabaremos con los terroristas que
amenazan a nuestro pueblo y mantendremos
a eeuu lejos de las guerras
interminables en el exterior
y vamos a designar jueces y fiscales que
crean en aplicar la ley y no en aplicar
su propia agenda política
lo cual es ilegal vamos a asegurar
justicia igualitaria para personas de
todas las razas religiones colores
credos vamos a respetar sus libertades
religiosas y defender su derecho a
portar y poseer armas
[Aplausos]
y si logramos su segunda enmienda no
tiene ni una sola oportunidad eso se los
puedo decir yo lo he protegido
vamos a proteger a medicare y a la
seguridad social siempre de manera
fuerte vamos a proteger los pacientes
con condiciones preexistentes y esa es
una promesa de todo el partido
republicano gracias que bien
y vamos a acabar con las seis cuentas
médicas sorpresa va pidiendo y exigiendo
transparencia y reduciendo los precios
de las primas de salud así como de los
medicamentos por prescripción vamos a
expandir el desarrollo energético
continuando siendo el número uno en el
mundo y manteniendo a eeuu independiente
de energéticamente
y para ustedes que aún tienen un auto
miren el precio de la gasolina lo han
visto tan bajo
[Aplausos]
vamos a ganar la carrera del 5g y
construir en los mejores sistemas de
defensa y de misiles que ya están bajo
construcción vamos a restaurar
completamente la educación patriótica a
nuestras escuelas para siempre proteger
siempre siempre proteger la libertad de
expresión en las universidades
[Aplausos]
y pusimos un gran castigo ahí no tiene
nada que ver si se mete con la libertad
de expresión las universidades tienen un
gran precio por pagar y es impresionante
lo abiertas que han estado últimamente
lanzaremos una nueva era de ambición en
el espacio de eeuu llevará a la primera
mujer a la mujer a la luna y seremos la
primera nación en plantar su hermosa
bandera en marte
[Aplausos]
esta es la agenda nacional unificadora
que va a unir este país entonces esta
noche le digo a todos los
estadounidenses que esta es la elección
más importante en la historia del país
nunca ha habido una diferencia tan
grande entre dos partidos dos individuos
dos ideologías dos filosofías o dos
visiones que la que existe en este
momento mis oponentes creen que estados
unidos es una nación depravada
nosotros queremos que nuestros hijos e
hijas conozcan la verdad
eeuu es la nación más excepcional y más
grande en la historia del mundo
[Aplausos]
nuestro país no fue construido por la
cultura de la cancelación o por códigos
de dialogo no somos una nación de
espíritus tímidos somos una
nación de personas independientes
patriotas y duros as somos una nación de
pioneros aventureros exploradores
personas que se rehúsan a ser amarrados
de ninguna manera los estadounidenses
tienen lo mejor en su mente tienen un
gran alma y tienen fuego en su corazón
no hay nadie como nosotros en la tierra
quiero que cada niño en este país sepa
que ustedes son parte de la mayor
aventura y la más emocionante en la
historia de la humanidad sin importar de
donde vengan sus familias sin importar
cuáles sean sus orígenes cualquiera aquí
puede triunfar con trabajo duro devoción
y determinación pueden alcanzar
cualquier objetivo y cualquier ambición
nuestros ancestros
navegaron por el océano para construir
una nueva vida en un nuevo continente se
enfrentaron a los inviernos cruzaron los
ríos
subieron los picos se enfrentaron a los
peligros del bosque y avanzaron desde el
amanecer hasta el anochecer no tenían
dinero no tenían fama pero se tenían
unos abuelos amaban a sus familias
amaban a su país y amaban a su dios
cuando se presentó la oportunidad
tomaron sus biblias
empacaron se subieron a sus vagones y se
fueron hacia el oeste para la próxima
aventura los rancheros los mineros y los
cowboys y los sheriff los campesinos
pasaron por el mississippi
para crear nuevas fronteras nacieron
leyendas
y construyeron sus casas hermosas tiene
sus ranchos tuvieron después comunidades
después pueblos y con el tiempo grandes
centros de industria y comercio
eso es lo que ellos fueron los
estadounidenses crearon su futuro
nosotros no derivamos en el pasado somos
la nación
que ganó una revolución que acabó con el
fascismo y la tiranía y que llevó a
miles a la libertad
construimos los ferrocarriles los
grandes buques creamos los edificios más
altos del mundo revolucionando las
industrias y creando una nueva era de
descubrimientos científicos creamos las
tendencias en arte y música en radio y
en el cine y en el deporte y en la
literatura y lo hicimos todo con steve
de confianza porque eso es lo que somos
cuando nuestra manera de vida se ha
visto amenazada nuestros héroes
respondieron al llamado de
los estadounidenses se levantaron con
balas y bayonetas para rescatar la
libertad no tuvieron miedo pero eeuu no
se detuvo ahí miramos hacia el cielo y
seguimos avanzando
construyamos construimos un cohete y lo
lanzamos al espacio lo hicimos para que
esos grandes patriotas pudieran saludar
nuestra maravillosa bandera
estadounidense plantada en la superficie
de la luna para eeuu nada es imposible
los próximos cuatro años vamos a probar
que somos dignos de este maravilloso
legados alcanzando nuevas alturas y
mostraremos que el mundo
para eeuu existe un sueño y no está más
allá de su alcance juntos somos no nadie
nos pueda detener nadie nos puede
derrotar porque juntos somos los
ciudadanos orgullosos de los eeuu de
américa
y el 3 de noviembre
[Aplausos]
haremos que eeuu se sea más seguro vamos
a hacer que este país sea más fuerte
haremos que el país sea más orgulloso y
haremos que eeuu sea más grande de lo
que nunca jamás ha sido estoy muy pero
muy orgulloso de ser el nominado del
partido republicano los amo a todos que
dios los bendiga dios bendiga a estados
[Aplausos]
[Música]